this Sunday there'll be a new lesson for
those who have recently accepted faith
those who embraced Islam accepted Islam
this lesson is for
you as they say Glad Tidings to the
Believers why because as a new Muslim
you need to know how to believe in Allah
to carry out W which is ation to pray to
Allah correctly likewise how to interact
with other Muslims correctly a lot of us
Embrace Faith alhamdulillah but we
knowum Friday prayer we need to know
more than that we need to know for
example the very basics of how to enter
the mid the DU we said the invocation so
this lesson is for you those who
embraced Faith recently if You' been
Muslim for a year or two still come
along you know all of those people M
that accepted Islam at the D table this
is for you inshallah so this lesson
likewise is one not to be missed why as
they
say knowledge is a means to All Things
virtuous how many Muslims do we know all
they know maybe a few things from Islam
and he never truly went out and learned
now is your time it's free there's no
charge and it's with our brother
Muhammad on a Sunday at 4 p.m. so please
don't miss out may Allah bless you